it's the interview that has shaking the
world watched by millions across the
globe caused extraordinary controversy
and almost ended a career its peers
versus yay
and this is the post Morgan the only
show that can sense a part-time National
Treasure and full-time National pleasure
Piers Morgan because he's not here I'm
Josh Peters and I'm Archie manners
really achieving something that Piers
Morgan uncensored never has popular
hosts we're here to go through Piers big
interviews dissect the controversial
moments and discover what happened next
and today we've got a very special show
for you joining us today is talk TV
regular JJ and cob an entertainment
correspondent Rebecca Toomey welcome to
discuss what might just be Yee's last
ever interview
his name is is yay so it was Kanye and
then it got shortened to yay that's
right whatever Mr West an interview
appears and if we're gonna play that
game we might as well call Piers Morgan
P Morgan but whatever let's move on
there's just no need for that anyway I
vote Nate yay we're all here so we might
as well get on with the show Joshua if
you missed all two hours of yay giving
his views on everything from Karens to
Kim's George Floyd to Jewish people yes
it was an interview that had it all
here's a little taste it is racism when
you say I'm going down
Pierce how much money are you worth not
as much as you sadly you're being a
Karen
I will say I'm sorry for the people that
I heard so it's been a week it's had
over 10 million views it's got drama
rudeness appalling opinions and an
almost humble apology but now we've had
time to reflect on the entire thing JJ
and Rebecca what are our first
impressions of this interview yeah
pretty good it's Kanye doing Kanye
basically or yay doing doing yay if
you're proper fan of Kanye you will know
these opinions anyway he's been saying
it his music's been saying in interviews
for years him going la la la is what he
taught his kids to run and tell his kids
to be quiet or shut up and go la la la
la la and that would calm the kids down
to listen to their father he said
himself in this interview I'm an
Entertainer and didn't he just entertain
he did exactly what he is born on this
planet to do which is cause controversy
and entertain us and I was thoroughly
entertained well on that we can't go
through the entirety interview because a
lot of it just looked like this
[Music]
you're interrupting me now do it or this
hey boy don't finish I told you oh don't
treat me like a boy then so yes I mean a
lot of it was too adult or supposedly
adult men screaming at each other
like children which was astonishing but
beyond that it was very entertaining it
was thoroughly entertaining because
Kanye wasn't I don't think he was
performing I think this is the real
Kanye where we've got and credit appears
he did pull out you know all the stops
to get Kenny to react and apart from a
little bit of quiet walking off he
didn't quite see any too many theatrics
I think this was real Kanye yeah I felt
like out of all the interviews and
physics I've watched in this one he
seemed I don't want to say nervous but a
bit more
didn't want to be too outspoken and I
would speak over Kanye I felt like he
let him speak a lot and he was actually
quite reserved Kanye West is the biggest
celebrity appeared Saturday show he's
got more followers than anyone else he's
more influential than anybody else ever
had so he needed to keep him on side and
keep him there as long as possible so
Rebecca you're quite right you said that
the interview is extremely entertaining
which it was I loved it but was it
necessary and helpful and informative do
you think helpful and informative to who
though I don't think it did kind of any
harm doing it but I don't think it is in
particularly good I think it was just
his platform to explain I think make the
rest of us questions I think that's what
Kenya's all about he's not about
deliberately causing controversy he's
actually there trying to make us all
question a bit more and I think actually
for the first time piercinged a little
bit like he might be questioning
something he did seem later on in the
interview which we'll get to to kind of
agree with some of what Kanye was saying
and I didn't know that that was a tactic
to let Kanye speak more and feel loved
or whether peers as mine was genuinely
changing there is this thing about
genius people that are geniuses can
often be just Geniuses but there's also
an edge to them aside of them that can
come across as a little bit sporadic and
random I mean how close is Kanye to
genius and how close is he just to
random streams of Consciousness he's in
that some sweet spot isn't he between
genius and almost unstable kind of gets
an unfair rap because
um he calls himself a rap god and in
terms of rap music and production
generally he is a god Jay-Z can say the
same thing Jay-Z made a song saying I am
a God and everyone's like that's cool no
it's Jay-Z because he's quieter with it
so Kanye has a different um standard
publicly people people jump on anything
he says at all they were harassing for
it he is the most influential person in
the world more so than back Obama he's
not the most influential person in the
world
if you could imagine that somebody took
a time machine and transported someone
from the 1890s that's basically Archies
before we were paid to host this I'd be
honest I've never heard
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
went out and copied his style of
clothing and you see a generation of
kids dressing in oversized baggy hoodies
etc etc and the nude palettes that's
from Kanye West he's hugely influential
now I don't think we can talk about this
interview without addressing uh Kanye's
response to the accusations of
anti-Semitism that were thrown towards
him so let's have a look at his defense
of that I'm a bit sleepy tonight but
when I wake up I'm going Defcon 3 on
Jewish people I was gonna talk about all
of the contracts
all of the missed dealings that I dealt
with as an Entertainer you're not saying
Jewish businessman accountants whatever
that you've had a problem with you're
basically saying in that statement all
Jewish people wonderful racism
racism it is racism when you say I'm
going down
okay so I'll say this
would it be would would I have grown
into the box you want me to go on if I
say to specify the business people that
have raped my people that just so happen
to be
Jewish right so there's a lot to unpack
here and it's obviously slightly more of
a serious subject than we might have
previously been discussing later in the
interview Kanye suggests that he was
fighting fire with fire in that he's
been the victim of racism and the saying
he's going to go death Con 3 on all
Jewish people is a way of retaliating
against that we almost get an apology
out of him which we'll come to later but
JJ what's your instant reaction to that
tweet going Defcon 3 on Jewish people
and then Rebecca will come to you in
terms of what he said on the show um the
Tweet to me is uh anti-semitic and I
don't like and symptoms let's call it
racism like it's right it's a racist
tweet
Kanye should have specified business
people instead of saying um
all Jews because that is just
horrendously and Semitic but it is
what's ironic and tragic is that the
claims he makes of the the Jewish people
control the media Etc et cetera he says
some anti-semitic and then he gets
canceled and loses two billion he can
now go and say oh you see the Jews are
controlling everything which is just
ludicrous so I don't know how we're
going to convince him that he's
incorrect about this there's no way of
convincing him yeah it's interesting
isn't it because he's literally taken
isolated isolated incidents from his own
life yeah and then
said that that is the way it is for for
all for Jewish people which is just
basically
everything racism and anti-Semitism
often stems from taking an isolated
incident in someone's life and then
saying that this is the way it is I've
only ever had racism from white people
my whole life but that doesn't mean that
all white people are racist yeah you two
are but
you know
Josh particularly absolutely because
when you work with South African anyway
Rebecca Josh's personal relationships
aside Rebecca what did you make of what
he said in the interview with peers so
we've got that tweet talking about going
Defcon 3 on Jewish people and then it
almost seems to double down in the
interview and make things worse for
himself
in a way he does but I think this excuse
of oh he was going to sleep on it and
then start making these accusations out
and making it more clear here he was
referring to nobody does that unaware
nobody sends half of a tweet or a thread
and then goes oh I'll just wait and
carry this on we all know social media
is instant and I think he knows exactly
what he's doing he knew that would cause
a rocket he this is a guy let's remember
2009 the VMAs when he infamously
interrupted Taylor Swift's acceptance
speech he knows what he's doing and he
creates Maximum Carnage and maximum
attention so I think he I think he's
genuine upset that he might have upset
people but he's not sorry for what he
did what I find interesting it is
exactly that point we were talking about
earlier
does he know what he's doing is this
conscious is this deliberate or is there
any veil of forgiveness or understanding
because actually maybe he's he's just
completely are you going to use Mental
Health Card here I'm not going to use
Mental Health Card I it's not for me to
speculate on his mental health at all
but normal people arguably that are
mentally sound some would say Do not
behave like that does he I suppose let
them do as well does he have a defense
at all for that kind of behavior or do
you think he's absolutely consciously
and deliberately doing it I mean you
cannot defend racism that's obviously
completely obvious but I think the way
in which he does things and the
character that he is why are we
surprised that Kanye West did that and
why are we spread he's been canceled I
think he's my own defenseman would be
that he is miscommune miscommunicated
himself he won't say one thing and it's
come out sounding completely wrong which
is also odd then because he's one of the
greatest lyricists of all time one
broader point I want to pick up there
which has to do with all of this is in
that interview did you think Kanye had a
clear idea of what he wanted to say and
how the interview would go or was he
just jumping around from different
streams of Consciousness and saying the
first thing that came to his mind I
think he does jump around a lot because
he's this great creative brain in my
opinion and I think he does go on one
different tangent and suddenly he'll be
talking and the argument moves another
way but I do think he wanted to make his
point I do think he was it wasn't sort
of coerced into this this is something
Kenya wanted to do and I think he
genuinely wants to apologize to people
he's upset but he's not apologizing for
the points that he makes which means he
might do it again although ironically
for a show that's flying in the face of
Castle culture we've now learned that
yay can't name Mr Westerly
disappropriate whatever he wants to be
called has now been canceled as a result
of his comments he's lost sponsorship
deals and a huge amount of support as
you mentioned though he did offer an
apology so let's see that before we hear
what I'll have to make of it I will say
I'm sorry for the people that I heard
with the Defcon the the confusion that I
call I feel like I can't I cause hurt
and confusion and I'm sorry for the
families of the people that had nothing
to do with the the trauma that I had
been through and that I use my platform
where you say hurt people hurt people
and I I was hurt I was frustrated so
Rebecca Kanye has now had numerous
commercial deals canceled yeah literally
canceled
was that deserved
I just don't think you can counsel
someone like it's not actually possible
someone with his amount of money in
Prestige if he was to set up another
line of trainers or clothing or his own
record label he can do that he's well
connected with his own money so in terms
of actually being canceled long term and
we're still talking about him if
someone's canceled that's it they're
erased they don't work anymore no one
talks about them absolutely but do you
think it was deserved that he lost those
commercial deals he did lost the Adidas
deal and I think yeah
Adidas
[Laughter]
what else did you do shop at McCann
very rude co-host interrupted me do you
think it was justified that they dropped
him from those Partnerships yes of
course no Big Brand wants to be
associated with that kind of stuff it
does seem JJ that in all of the
controversy that surrounds yay's life
we've moved into this new phase now
where particularly since piers's
interview it's
hammer time in terms of Brands canceling
him do you think this do you think his
position amongst the public and his fans
has changed in any way his fans are
still Autumn go on Instagram still get
the same amount of likes Kanye West was
a producer who couldn't get taken
serious as a rapper he then became one
of the most successful rappers of all
time he then was a um an Aspire fashion
designer no one took seriously he then
became the most influential fashion
designer of his generation he was also
bankrupted he was in debt of like 200
million and became the richest black man
in history this is not the end of Kanye
West you can't cancel no he seems to be
like I think a lot of people are quite
frustrated with the way the world is at
the moment and that you can't say
certain things and you have to behave in
a certain way now obviously he has gone
way too far in the other direction but
do we think that's a result of the sort
of build up of the last few years of of
cancel culture yeah absolutely like I
was saying earlier he he knows what he's
doing he's a very clever person and he
deliberately is trying to make us all
think and all question and all look at
you know what what is social media doing
with Twitter doing what is the power of
celebrity why are we not questioning
things okay to disagree with Piers
Morgan and lots of people do it's okay
to disagree with Kanye West
following on to that then yes or no is
Kanye West anti-Semitic
yes
yeah he is and yet neither of them want
to cancel it anyways now we've heard our
panelists opinions and no one cares
about ours but how did the internet
react this is the internet reacting on a
reaction show about the reaction to
Piers Morgan's reaction to What ye said
in the reaction to Piers Morgan's
questions nice I will say I'm sorry for
the people that I heard with the Defcon
the the confusion that I call I feel
like I can't I can't he's saying
confusion because he's implying that
what he said was not wrong and the
confusion is that it was implying that
he didn't do anything wrong yeah he's
literally used using legitimate black
trauma which she has also participated
in and contributed to in contemporary
Society to turn around and be like oh
well this is what the [ __ ]
that's crazy
this man Kanye West just turned the
interview in the conversation into being
about money that is not the direction
that Piers Morgan is trying to go I'm
sure many other artists
appears to validate his feelings about
that because you don't care he's just
trying to say bro
wait I'm gonna finish
anyway the other big talking point was
get his comments on the death of George
Floyd questioning whether the coroner's
reporting to his death was accurate
indeed Floyd's family announcing for 250
million dollars let's have a look at the
clip the cause of death was what that
policeman did with his name
well why would the coroner lie what
makes you believe that why would the
current a lie because he could get paid
to lie because he could get paid the
library yeah I watched it I watched it
but the majority of the press I have the
right to question because that that
videotape was used to traumatize my
people and force us into the Democratic
vote so we can have 20 different
perspectives on how JFK died but us as
black people not only are can we only
vote one way we're not allowed to have
any other perspectives I don't think
it's in question about what actually
killed him it was that police officer
what is in question it isn't it is in
question I'm questioning JJ what did you
make of Kanye's response
uh is foreign diamonds conspiracy theory
whole of questioning everything
um way too much I think George Floyd is
particularly a sensitive issue um for
everyone uh in the world but the fact
that George Troy's family is suing him
for 250 million dollars Kanye donated I
think three million or two million
dollars to the family so that George
Floyd's daughter could end up well could
have money to go to university and
family can live a slightly better life
so I think it is
um harsh for me to be suing him for 250
million dollars regardless of his
comments but
should we question and things
particularly if you have a platform like
Kanye West it is I think a truth
universally acknowledged that Derek
Chauvin was responsible for the death of
George Floyd and yes at the beginning of
that interview appears guys it's not the
question
I'm questioning it and by the end Pierce
goes you have the right to question it
who does have the right question should
we question things like that that are so
sensitive always we're journalists
journalists we've been trained our
entire careers to question every fact to
give an opinion to never just take
anything as oh yes that's fine we accept
this so I think anybody I think the
whole point of Kenya is that he wants us
to question it and he's just picking I
think a very big case he's very amazed
he's a rapper so he's he's a creative
he's allowed to create people the right
therefore to question the death of
somebody who universally acknowledged
and found in court by a Coroner's report
to have died in a particular way ever
everybody is allowed to question and now
everyone has a platform because of
social media but I think it comes down
to the way in which you do question it
by nature of of questioning things you
are going to be upsetting a lot of
people so I suppose it's how you do it
in a respectful way which is a really
difficult thing Kanye questions
everything you come back to his first
album College Dropout he was rapping
about the fact that before he even could
afford to buy a house when he got his
Advanced check for his album he went to
the Jewel and bought loads of gold and a
fancy car because that's what
stereotypically rappers All Falls Down
is is largely about that yeah exactly
but and that was like way before its
time of sort of acknowledging that
people spend a lot of money on things to
cover up their insecurities yeah
precisely so Kanye's made that his whole
life has been about questioning
everything you're right the way he
questions George Floyd's um murder I'll
call it is disrespectful I think to the
family
um and to The Wider public everyone was
affected by that not just the family so
that that doesn't paint me in the
greatest of life okay so perhaps we
shouldn't take everything yes is at face
value because if we did there'd be
absolutely no reason to have anyone else
on the planet because yay knows it all
and yeah you can do it all take a look
the idea for Django I pitched to Jamie
Foxx and Quentin Tarantino as the video
for gold digger as I'm like the top five
writers in human exist in human history
but I also believe that I'm extremely
brilliant and I'm here to make the world
a better place
I can like make a dinosaur out of a
femur me a person a successful a
successful influential extremely
extremely extremely attractive person to
get to that point Matisse more Matisse
than Picasso more African cubism than
Matisse uh so I just do that I thought
that's kind of for the Liberals and
that's the funny thing
when you say you're more matistan
Picasso as somebody who's a fan of
Matisse and Picasso and she'll spend a
lot of time in in Santa Fe where they
all used to paint together
foreign
now what really worries me about that is
it reminds me of early clips of Donald
Trump and if you look very carefully at
the hat that he is wearing I don't know
if you noticed what year is on yay's hat
it's 2024 where he might end up running
for president do you think there's a
chance of that yeah the chance of it but
he's not going to win clearly he's not
going to win he hasn't got enough
support across um White America to win
but the thing with Kanye West bragging
the reason you're making fun of it is
because as a society without people
bragging Lionel Messi Ronaldo they don't
go around saying I'm best footballer in
the world other people say about them
but when someone else takes it and says
actually I'm the best footballer in the
world you say oh well that's arrogant
you shouldn't be saying that but
everything Kanye said there I have to
agree with he's extremely extremely
brilliant he's as good as Monet yeah he
is for what he does for certainly as a
creative I think he he's on that level
yeah said he was one of the top five
writers of all time
but you haven't seen anything you don't
know a single Kanye West William
Shakespeare
TV
yes to be or not to be there are
thousands of Better lyrics
dropouts three of the most meaningless
words that lead to its probation and
failure
do you think a lot of his insecurities
maybe come from the fact that he works
so hard not took so long to actually
make it in the industry I've just
watched his documentary on I think Jimmy
Cooper's better
but he you know he he he got put down
all throughout his career that's it and
struggled to make it to the top and it
took what 10 15 years of of being
writing all the best songs producing 10
15 years and this is as good as it's
getting I don't think excuse me this is
pretty good thank you
but but JJ do you think that plays into
his insecurities that sort of forever
being held down now he is on the top and
he's made it and he feels the need to
constantly brag and talk about yeah
because like I said earlier um when he's
trying to be a rapper the rappers said
Jay-Z and Dame Dash said you're not a
rapper We're not gonna put you on I
think but he's trying to do fashion the
Fashion World rejected him yet he's a
comp he's gone into every industry he's
gone into gone into and taking it over
Nike didn't want to pay him the same
rule is that they'd pay a professional
athlete to do Trainers for them even
though he did one train because he's a
singer
he designs them like and it outsold
athlete trainers we have to we have to
we have to move on got big challenge of
that in my ear so I'm sorry shut up okay
Jake I'm coming now to the end of our
inaugural show but there's still time
for a segment which we're calling things
that age terribly
[Music]
Pierce how much money are you worth not
as much as you sadly
exactly so take my advice maybe you'll
get richer
well that's all we've got time for today
thanks to our guests JJ and Coby and
Rebecca Toomey do join us next time
please can't be bothered to present his
own shows on YouTube because he's
spending so much time with Picasso Monet
and Sancho pain until then goodbye
goodbye
[Applause]
Josh is the looks and the Brain that's
normally